remember when everyone went nuts about
the bear attack scene in the revenant
even though everything looked shockingly
real it turns out the CGI bear and Leo
were just really good actors unlike that
scene however many others seemingly
unreal movie moments were actually done
with practical effects and very real
sometimes death-defying conditions here
are some movie scenes you thought were
fake but were actually real hanging from
the hood Zoe Bell is an accomplished
stunt performer she caught Quentin
Tarantino's attention when she worked as
Emma Thurman's double in Kill Bill saw
the director cast her in 2007's death
Proof Belle's spent the better part of
six weeks amazingly not dying while
hanging onto the hood of a Dodge
Challenger while speeding around
desolate Eastern European roads the
result is a harrowing sequence in which
she clings to the challengers hood as
Kurt Russell slams his car into hers
again and again why the end of it I mean
we were we were clicking at 80 or 90
miles an hour at 140 miles I mean that's
that's [ __ ] it would have been far too
ironic to die making a film called death
Proof anyhow the wind suits a remake of
Point Break was never really necessary
and especially not one that got rid of
the film's original surfers for well I
believed it like me the people behind
these robberies are extreme athletes
some of the world's top extreme athletes
were invited to do their own stunts the
wingsuit scene in particular was shot
with for athletes who did 60 jumps all
while going faster than a hundred and
forty five miles per hour according to
the film's behind-the-scenes featurette
the first time I watched those five guys
into that crack and I literally am like
why we are now watching one of the
greatest stunts that's ever been pulled
off by human beings next time it might
not be worth risking their lives for a
remake of a movie with stunning dialogue
like this let's take your shrapnel and
taste stock while you work wrap it in
your hands and rubbing it on your face
the old road pulls almost every action
sequence in 2015's Mad Max fury road was
created with human stunt performers
culminating in one insane final battle
featuring weapon firing bad guys riding
giant poles mounted onto speeding
vehicles stunt coordinator guy Norris
told Rolling Stone that is
the Soleil performer trained the
stuntmen in Chinese pole work during an
eight-week course that's an interesting
way to phrase it
the actors were repeatedly smashed into
the ground and run over by Giants
beating tires the entire movie is an
astonishing adrenaline rush and the fact
that this scene was pulled off by real
people who weren't killed in the process
just makes it even more incredible vanes
escape Christopher Nolan's love of
practical effects is no secret so it's
no surprise the director ramped up the
real-life action for 2012's The Dark
Knight Rises tarnishing this word in the
opening scene the villainous Bane blows
a plane in half and escapes the rack by
being pulled on to another plane by
henchmen dangling from ropes no big deal
right when discussing the scene at the
Tribeca Film Festival
Nolan revealed they dropped a real plane
out of the sky that means real people
dropped a real plane out of the sky for
a movie about a guy who dresses like a
bat seems perfectly reasonable speaking
of insane plane stunts that's one way to
hitchhike it's well-known that Tom
Cruise does much of his own stunt work
in the Mission Impossible series but
some of his exploits defy belief
case in point 2015's rogue nation where
Cruz pulls off at least one
irresponsibly crazy maneuver hanging
from the side of a massive cargo plane
during takeoff while the dangers
involved with this stunt are obvious
Cruz could have been killed if so much
as a random bird flew into it I mean but
you're getting hit with jet fuel and jet
fuel and that you know I just didn't
want to get hit by a bird or any
particle you know no Lucy that that's
something out seriously I got hit by a
little stone about that big and we're
going so fast huh luckily it hit my rear
bike I thought it broke my rib so they
had to do it in one take right think
again Cruz did it eight times
there's dedication to a role and then
there's whatever you call what Tom
Cruise does
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
about your favorite movie stunts